MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you guys for joining
us for another guest chefs
at Google LAX.
We're very excited to
have chef Dakota Weiss.
And this is also going to
be our first guest chef
event here at Google LAX.
It's branded under to the Gap.
So thanks for being
a part of this.
Today Dakota of Top Chef fame
and 9:30 in The Backyard,
as well as the W Hotel,
but specifically 9:30
in The Backyard
from Westwood, is
going to do a low calorie, low
fat, three course meal for you
guys that you can pull
off in 20 minutes.
DAKOTA WEISS: Well, possibly.
MALE SPEAKER: We're going to
give you all the time you like.
She's going to give you
the basic steps right here.
I just didn't want to
put any pressure on you.
DAKOTA WEISS:
Seriously, oh my god.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
DAKOTA WEISS: Cool guys.
Thank you for
coming, and ladies.
So I prepared this
low calorie, which
is very not so much my nature.
I'm really into the butter,
and the cream, and the cheese.
However, we're in California,
we're next to the beach.
It's Google, I know everybody's
very conscious these days
about what they're eating,
organic, and fresh,
and light, and stuff.
So I created this for
you all, just for you.
We're going to start with a raw
vegan dish which actually, this
is squash carpaccio version 3.1.
I've taken this dish
and kind of changed it
throughout the seasons just
update it a little bit.
But it is something that
we do serve at 9:30,
but that's version 3.0.
So don't get those confused.
So basically we'll
get started here.
We're going to take
a cousa squash.
Does anybody know what
a cousa squash is?
It's also known as the
Mexican Gray Squash.
It's obviously kind of a
cross between a yellow squash
and a zucchini.
But this particular
squash, and the reason I
use this one is because
it has less seeds.
And the meat inside of it has
got almost a creamy texture
to it.
So we're just going to slice
the top off, shave it very thin.
Watch your fingers.
If you don't have a man--
does anybody cook at home?
All right.
Does everybody have
a mandolin at home?
It is one of the
most fabulous tools,
I highly recommend you have.
It slices just about anything,
including your fingers.
So please be careful.
So we're just going to kind
of line this down the plate.
This really is technically
like a five minute dish,
if even that.
And it's really
delicious and fresh.
Well, you know in
California everything's kind
of in season year round.
But it's primarily summer.
We're going that thin.
You can't quite read
a newspaper through it
but it's still
pretty paper thin.
So we're going to add on to
this a yuzu soy white truffle
vinaigrette.
The most awesome thing
about this vinaigrette
is you don't need any equipment.
You just need a cup and a lid.
And so I call it my
shaker vinaigrette.
So we're going to start with
a little yuzu juice, which
I'm pretty sure you can probably
get at Whole Foods these days.
If not, there's plenty
of Asian markets
around that you can get it.
This is a little white soy
sauce, rice vinegar, and then
our white truffle oil.
And you don't need to add any
salt to this because the soy
sauce adds enough of that.
That's it.
How easy that was.
And we're going to
season our squash here.
I use a little bit
of Maldon salt, which
is a salt that
comes from England.
And it's these really
beautiful crystals.
When you come up you
can kind of see them.
We're going to add a little
shaved Serrano pepper to this
to give it a little spice.
Kind of sprinkle it around
kind of like a Pollock design,
I'd like to say.
And then we're going to add some
fresh sliced heirloom tomatoes.
This dish is already
screaming summer, right?
Don't you want to get in
your bikini and bathing suit
right now?
And I toasted earlier some
fresh sunflower seeds just
to give it a little
crunch and texture.
And then the dressing you
can be very liberal with it
because it doesn't
have a lot of oil.
And it's really
packed with flavor,
and you want to make sure that
the squash gets completely
doused in it.
And then lastly,
we're just going
to add some aromatic
herbs to it.
And it can be whatever you like.
If you've got something
growing in your garden,
I highly recommend those.
But we're going to add
a little bit of basil,
and then a little bit
of micro bulls blood.
All right, and that
is your first course.
Anybody want to try it?
Yeah, all right.
I'm going to come over here.
And you guys can
just kind of come up.
Bring you some forks.
You just pick them
right off there.
Yeah, go for it.
You'll see it's very
light and refreshing.
What do you think?
You guys like it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAKOTA WEISS: It's surprising,
well in my opinion,
it's always surprising that
something raw and vegan
tastes so good just because
I'm not a vegetarian.
But by golly, it sure can.
And you saw how
easy it is to do.
You just need a mandolin.
And you can do it
with a knife if you've
got mad skills at
home with a knife.
Go for it, but yeah.
It's so simple to
make good food.
All right.
So our second
course, we're going
to make a slow
roasted arctic char.
Does anybody know
what arctic char is?
AUDIENCE: Fish.
DAKOTA WEISS: Yeah.
It's very similar
to salmon and trout.
I like to call it the sea trout.
And we're going to serve
it with a lemon shitaki
broth and some roasted
spring vegetables.
That's where you guys go Oooh.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
DAKOTA WEISS: Ahh, right.
I'll queue you.
Next time it'll be this.
OK, so we're going to
start with our broth.
So this starts to get
steeping in with the shitakis
and the lemon-- very simple.
Some dried shitakis.
You can get these at
any of the Asian markets
off Sawtell or the
big one off Pico.
Can never the name of that one.
And then I like
to take the lemons
and zest them right
into the shitakis.
When you zest any
citrus, I don't
know if I can get this on
camera, but it's pretty cool.
It kind of explodes
with essential oils.
And when you twist it, kind of
have to be really close to it,
you can see the oils
kind of shoot off.
And even more, so
you can smell it.
So what I'm trying
to do with this broth
is captured those
oils into the broth.
That's why I don't zest
them ahead of time.
No, if it's not going
to-- the shitakis
are so powerful that
you're not going
to get any sort of
bitterness from it.
And then you can make this with
water if you're a pescaterian.
That's fine, but I chose to
make it with a chicken stock
to give just a
little more flavor.
And then basically,
you're just going
to kind of let this steep
for about 20 minutes.
Once it's ready
and it comes off,
it's going to be a
beautiful, dark brown color.
Can you guys see that?
It's got a really nice, golden
brown, mushroom-ey flavor to it
as well, which you'll see.
See, I'd let it steep
like this 20 minutes.
And then you can
strain everything off.
If you want to season it with
a little bit of soy sauce,
to add a little salt
to it, that's fine.
If you want to go low sodium
just leave it as it is.
Because all the other
vegetables and the fish
have a lot of flavor
on them as well.
I try to not use too
much, because I really
want to intensify
and get the most
flavor I can out of
all the ingredients.
Dried shitakis can
be a little expensive
but they do pack a punch.
So a little does go a long way.
And then when you do strain it
off, really kind of press it.
Try to get all the liquid and
everything out of the shitakis
once we're over.
So that's going to go.
While this is on
your stove boiling,
you can get your fish ready.
So arctic char,
like I said, it's
this really gorgeous
pink fleshed
fish, very similar to salmon.
Sort of what I like to
call it the sea trout.
And it's got this
really gorgeous skin
with these little, beautiful
pink polka dots on it.
I don't know about you,
but I love polka dots,
so that makes me love
this fish even more.
Really simple to season with
salt and pepper, both the skin
and the flesh.
Let your pan get pretty warm.
Just put a little bit
of olive oil in it,
and then you're going to
start it skin side down.
My little tester
is usually to grab
just a little bit of liquid.
Flick it in there.
If you hear that,
you're good to go.
Stand back, you want
to burn your face.
So once you have
this in your pan
you're going to let the
skin get super crispy.
It's going to take about
two to three minutes.
At that point, you're going
to keep it on the skin
and you can pop it in
the oven at about 325
and just slowly roast it.
Is everybody familiar
with cooking fish
and how it should feel, look?
What?
Why not?
What I like to tell people, the
easiest way, or how I learned
is when you see that albumin
start to come out of it,
and that's like
the little, white,
it looks like cheese
curds kind of.
That's when you know your
fish is starting to cook.
Arctic char is one of
those great fish where
you don't need to
cook at all the way.
I like to serve it medium.
But I do know people that
like it completely well
done as well, such as my mother.
All right, well hot now.
So you can see once
it starts to smoke,
you know your skin's going
to get crispy like that.
See on the bot-- well,
that's a little burnt.
We'll look at this
a little bit better.
Nice, crispy, golden brown skin.
Nevermind that one.
That's why we always
bring two pieces.
So you're going to
take this unburnt one
and pop it in the oven for
about 230 degrees, sorry, 330.
Let it roast.
When you start to see the
little white albumin come out,
then you know you're right
about where you want it.
You don't need to
cook it all the way,
because we're going to add
it into our warm broth.
And as it sits in
that broth, it's
going to continue to carry
over cooking as well.
For this, I think
the vegetables,
I used in baby carrots,
beats, and turnips.
But I suggest the best thing
because these are really
beautiful right now and
at the farmer's market.
But the best thing to
do is honestly just
go to the farmer's market.
See what vegetables they have.
It's better to cook
seasonally, as we all know,
and to buy your stuff
from the market.
So what I did with these
is I took the carrots,
peeled them lightly, and
just quickly blanched them.
The baby turnips, same thing.
See the cute little guys here.
And then just quartered them.
And then the beets
are the only thing
that I roasted in the skin,
olive oil, salt, pepper,
oven at 350 for
roughly-- if it's
about that size,
roughly 25 minutes.
Same thing with the
fish, is you don't
want to cook the vegetables all
the way through, because you're
going to put them
in a hot broth.
And that's going to continue
to cook them as well.
Plus we all know you're going
to retain work nutrition and all
the vitamins from al dente
vegetables as opposed
to mushy vegetables.
Right.
Let this heat up a little.
Any questions so far?
Because we have a
little lull here.
We're going to wait for
our vegetables to heat.
So hit me.
What's that?
What about it?
Well the cool thing about
dried mushrooms in particular,
it's very similar to
canned vegetables, tomatoes
in particular.
When they pick the
mushrooms to dry them,
they're at their best ripeness.
They're like prime condition.
They take them, and
they dehydrate them.
So when you rehydrate
them, they're
just perfect, more or less.
Same thing with canned tomatoes.
Everybody's like oh,
canned food is awful.
But tomatoes are
really the only one
that I would ever use
this example with.
But they pick them when
they're just perfectly ripe.
That's when they can them,
and they're perfectly ripe
no matter whatever
you do with them.
You go to the
store, you're going
to get a mealy tomato no
matter what almost always.
Because it's not necessarily
the season for them.
Does that make sense?
What else you got?
Come on, give me something.
Yeah?
Everybody knows the Santa
Monica Farmer Market's probably
the biggest and the best I would
say in LA as far as diversity
and all in all, the different
purveyors and everything where
you can get soap, oil,
beeswax, dates, and olives,
also to your proteins,
cheese, and vegetables.
A couple others
that I really like,
the Brentwood market is fun.
And plus, it's right
next to my hotel,
so it's easy to get there.
Downtown's got some pretty
cool ones coming up too,
especially on Sundays
I believe there's
one on Fourth and Spring, Fifth
and Spring, I take that back.
That's kind of a cool
farmer's market as well.
All time favorite farmer's
market in California
is San Luis Obispo.
Is anybody familiar
with that one?
It's probably the coolest.
It's every Thursday night,
and they shut down probably
three blocks of one street.
And each block has its own
band, all the restaurants
come out, there are restaurants
set up, these cool barbecues.
It's just super festive.
They've got food,
they've got dancing,
they've got gymnastics,
and comedians.
It's pretty cool, I
highly recommend it.
Plus SLO is just a really
awesome town as well.
Let's see how we're doing here.
So these veggies you
can prep ahead of time.
Let's see, sorry.
Very interesting, trying
to get it to get hotter.
Get hot.
I wish I had my inspector
gadget tools with me
today, and just did that.
All right.
These are going to take a
little long, or a little longer.
Come on, give me
some more questions.
Anybody, come on.
The popcorn?
Oh, that's a great question.
I can answer that.
Very simply, I take the popcorn,
and I air pop everything.
After that's done,
I make a toffee.
So none of it is vegan, although
I'm working on a vegan one
right now as I was shamed
at the artisinal market
for not having one.
So it's in the process.
But make a toffee base.
Whatever the flavor is,
like the Napa, nirvana,
I'll take two
gallons of red wine
and reduce it down to two cups.
Add that to the toffee.
Then you take the popcorn, and
you mix it all up together.
Then depending on what
goes in it, whether it's
rosemary or brie,
that particular one I
take brie pieces and
kind of spread it
throughout sheet tray.
And then they bake in
oven for about an hour.
Once they come out,
toss them with the rest
of the ingredients, rosemary,
crackers, whatever it may be.
And that's it.
Well we've had a test jar
for about a year and a half
just to kind of see
how it would hold.
And we opened it up
about two months ago,
and it was still
pretty good and crispy.
Yeah.
I don't suggest
holding it that long.
You put it in your
emergency basement kit.
To get, what was the last part?
Well any balsamic
I like, obviously
I love the aged
balsalmics, but I'm really
having this love affair right
now with golden balsalmics.
It's really sweet but it's
got a nice acidity to it.
And you can pretty much, Base
Cities has a great selection.
And they've got a couple
different golden balsalmics
there.
But any aged balsalmic in
barrel's the way to go.
Raw food recipes, I
wouldn't really know where.
I mean obviously
you can Google it.
I'm sure there are a
hundred places, that's
just like everyday language,
everybody knows that, right?
And I'm sure 100 different
websites would open up
for that.
However, you've
inspired me, and I
will put some raw
vegetable or dishes
in general up on my website
at chefdakota.com just for you
in a week.
Check back, it'll be there.
What's that?
Yeah, you have to be
really inventive and really
creative to make raw food in
my opinion, taste really good.
If you have a great
product it's going
to taste great no matter what.
But to make it
interesting and just step
outside of the normal kind
of chopped salad, raw thing,
then it takes a little
bit of creativity.
There is a restaurant, I
think it's called Salt Air,
and they make a really good
cashew nut cheese there.
Probably, I would assume it's
probably the same thought
process.
Yeah.
All right, we are almost
ready to plate here.
So all the time
has gone through.
Our fish is beautifully
cooked, right?
Our sauce has stepped,
and it tastes delicious.
Our vegetables are roasted,
and we're going to plate.
It's very exciting.
Everybody knows
the state law now
is to wear gloves
pretty much for anything
you do in the kitchen these
days, even bartenders.
So if you don't see your
bartender wearing their gloves,
you shame them.
I'm a glove person.
I prefer them just because I
go home, and I had two dogs.
And if I felt like
food I'll get mauled.
But I do know a lot of chefs,
sushi chefs in particular
are very upset about
it because it does,
it's not going to leave
a very strong flavor.
But when you're talking about
raw fish that's very oily
and it sucks up flavor it
can alter it a little bit.
But for the overall
health of everybody
it's probably just
better and safe.
All right, so we're going
to season our vegetables.
So this is going to be
our little sample bowl.
So we've got our gorgeous broth.
And you're going to
ladle that into the bowl.
It's not necessarily a soup, so
you don't want to do too much.
But once the fish goes in
there and the vegetables,
it's really going to soak
up a lot of that liquid.
And to make it even
more delicious.
We have our beautiful
cooked fish.
You can be your own artist and
put your vegetables however
you like.
If you're OCD, you can line up
all the carrots, all the beets.
And then we're
going to finish this
with a little bit
of pea tendrill
because it's what's in season.
You can just toss it
with a little olive
oil, a little salt.
Twirl it around.
Right on top there.
You probably can't
see in there too good.
But when you come up try
your sample you will.
All right.
Give me just one minute.
You guys ready to try this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAKOTA WEISS: Awesome.
Pea tendrills are
the leaves of peas.
Yeah.
And they're a little more
verdant, a little more grassy.
But they're just is
cute as they can be,
because they've got these
little spiral vines on them that
are just adorable.
And you'll see them all
over the market right now.
Anybody have any
other questions?
For what?
Harry's Berries.
Its all time best berries
I've ever had really,
and they're at the farmer's
market here in Santa Monica
every Wednesday and Saturday.
I've never seen them in a store.
So I'm not sure, I would
say probably yes for now.
But surely they've got
to be somewhere else.
But their farms are
not far from here.
They're Oxnard and Gaviota.
So I imagine they're in
stores probably more locally
to where their farms are.
Have you guys had
Harry's Berries?
It is like just
eating a strawberry.
You know that really intense,
fake strawberry flavor
you get out of candy sometimes?
It tastes just like that.
And it's so succulent,
and gorgeous, and sweet,
and delicious.
What's that?
Yeah, you'll be like this
is not a Harry's Berry,
I'm not eating it.
Does everybody eat fish in here?
All right, because I could
make a vegetarian one.
Oh, you know what?
I can make you some vegetables.
I forgot I put chicken
stock in the broth.
I'd hate to tell you it's
vegetarian, then it's not.
My brief moment
of forgetfulness.
All right, I'm just going to
get a couple ready for you guys,
and you can start coming up.
They're a little cumbersome
to eat in these little cups,
but get the point.
Does everybody have to go
back to work after this?
Yeah.
It's a nice break, right?
All right, you can start
coming up here if you like
and grab the ones with green.
And then fork right there.
And I'd say the
liquid you could,
once you eat the
fish and the carrots,
kind of do a little shot of it.
Well, I think everybody's go to
is probably a seitan or a tofu.
Like mushrooms are always
great although there's
no protein in there,
but to give you
that kind of steak-ey texture.
Those are always a go to as
well, especially portobellos.
Porcinis are great.
OK.
So for dessert in our very
healthy, light, low calorie
meal, we're going to make a
homemade almond milk yogurt.
Has anybody made yogurt before?
Very fun.
Any time I get the
chance to ferment
anything I get super excited.
And actually I was a little
intimidated at first to make
yogurt.
But just because it's
kind of scary process,
leaving stuff out and
hoping it magically
comes from milk to
this beautiful cream.
But if I can make it, I've got
to say anybody can make it.
Because I'm not much of a baker.
Not that you have to be
a baker to make yogurt,
but you have to be very precise
in your measurements and stuff.
OK.
So the first step to this
is to make your almond milk.
You're totally welcome
to just buy almond milk.
And there's some
great places that
actually make it artisinally
here in Los Angeles as well.
But it's so simple
to make, and I
feel like if you're going to
go through the hassle of making
your own yogurt, you might as
well just make the almond milk
from scratch.
It is just that easy.
The ratio for almond milk
is usually three to one.
One being the almonds,
and three being the water.
For a yogurt though, I take
it actually down to two to one
just so you're going to get
a more intense almond flavor.
And it'll help make the yogurt
a little bit thicker as well.
It helps if you have a really
awesome blender as well.
If you don't, you can buy,
they're called a nut milk bag.
And it's kind of basically
this really cool sieve.
And once you puree this you
would pour it into this bag
and you literally just
squeeze out all the liquid
from the milk.
And it keeps all the pulp.
If you have a badass
blender like this,
then I say just leave
the pulp in there
because it's going
to puree it enough
where it doesn't leave any
weird, fibery textures.
And plus, it's going to add
a little more flavor as well.
No, the almonds can be whole.
I just happen to have slivered.
You can toast them if you
want to toastier flavor to it,
or you can just leave them raw.
It's completely up
to you and how much
you would like your almond
milk to taste like almonds.
I've not, but I imagine
you can probably
make a milk out of any nut
as far as I'm concerned.
OK.
See how easy that was?
You have almond milk.
Awesome.
So you're going to take that.
You're going to strain
it or you're just
going to leave it as it is.
You're going to take
this almond milk.
There's two ways
you can make yogurt.
You can buy a culture
starter, which
is kind of like a
powdery substance.
If you want to
keep it completely
vegan then go with
the powdery substance.
If you don't care
it's vegan or not,
you can take any yogurt,
your favorite yogurt
as long as it has active
cultures inside of it,
and you just simply
add it to your milk.
I use clover yogurt.
It's local to California,
and they're just
a really good farm.
You just want to lightly
kind of stir it in there
because you don't want to upset
any of those cultures that
are in there, because
they're very sensitive.
Not unlike me sometimes.
Just give it a little stir.
You're going to cover it up.
You're going to find a place
somewhere in your house
or wherever you choose to make
this that's around 90 degrees.
If you don't have a
place that's that hot,
my little MacGyver rig is
if you have a heating pad,
or you can go to Target
and buy a heating pad,
take that heating pad.
Put it in a corner
in your kitchen.
Wrap this with just a
light towel around it,
and let it sit there
for eight hours.
Forget about it.
Don't even look at
it, it's like watching
a boiling pot of water, right?
After eight hours you're
going to refrigerate it
for about four hours without
opening it or messing with it.
After four hours
you're going to get
this beautiful
looking substance.
Right?
Don't be scared.
What you're going
to do with this part
is basically cheese cloth
into another container.
If you have really cool Mason
jars like I have the popcorn,
they make really
awesome little jars,
and they're cute to put them in.
And it's kind of hard to see.
But you can kind of see
the floating fermented part
where it's all coagulated.
Awesome.
And if you smell it, it smells
amazing, just like yogurt.
And this is going to separate
the liquid from the curds.
These are more, yeah.
This is big kitchen batch,
this little home batch.
Unless you like a lot of
yogurt, then by all means
go get a big kitchen batch.
So once this completely
strains you're
going get this
cool looking stuff.
And this is your yogurt.
It's gorgeous, it's going
to look a little curdled.
Don't be alarmed by that,
it's totally normal.
But it gets this
really amazing texture.
You can kind of see,
it's pretty thick.
The more you let it sit, the
thicker it's going to get.
And at this point it's
completely ready to go.
There's no sweetener in this.
Even though almond milk tends to
be a little sweet, once it goes
through the fermentation process
it adds that sourness to it.
So if you like,
you can add sugar,
or raisins, honey, maple syrup,
whatever it is that you like.
So for our purposes, we're
turning this into a dessert.
And we're just going to
take this beautiful yogurt
and layer it with some berries.
These are not Harry's
Berries for today.
If the market was open, I may
have been productive enough
to go get some.
But not today.
Then for this, I wanted to add
a little bit of a tropical note
to it.
So I brought some passion fruit.
Has anybody seen
passion fruit before?
It looks really kind of
boring, and almost like a rock.
Until you open it and you
get this gorgeous pink-ey,
orange, beautifulness.
So we're just going to scrape
a little bit of passion fruit
season seeds on there.
Yep.
It'll only scrape so much.
The seeds are really going
to be the only thing.
This white stuff in
there won't really
come off unless you're
super aggressive with it.
And then we're just
finish this off
with a little bit
of almond brittle
just to make it more
desert-ey, and also to give it
another fun, crunchy, texture.
And that is your
healthy dessert.
Ooh.
All right, here we go.
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
DAKOTA WEISS: All right,
who wants to try this?
Me, yeah.
Conveniently have
them done for you.
So does seem easy enough?
Do you feel confident you
could go home and make it?
Absolutely, yeah that's
the right answer.
And then if you want the
recipes for all of this
they will be uploaded on my
website later this evening.
Oh my lord, that is
a loaded question.
I'm going to have to go
with probably the simpler
things such as like
a beef bourguignon.
I really like the
comfort-ey, braised meats
that you really put
a lot of time into.
Yeah, I would say that.
Plus it's classic, and I
love those classic dishes.
And it reminds me of my grandma.
Underrated?
Well about six months ago I
probably would've said kale,
but now you can't
get away from kale.
It's pretty much everywhere.
I have to say just a lot
of the random bitter greens
like tot soy, lola rosa, frisee.
I think usually when
you get a mesclun salad
and you see all the
crazy lettuce in there,
people are like, I
don't want these weeds.
Why are they feeding me weeds?
Those weeds taste
really delicious.
And I don't think
they're utilized a lot.
What's that?
Do I eat Cajun foods?
Not too much, however
I did used to work
at the Ritz Carlton in Sarasota.
And my restaurant
there was based,
because it was on
the Gulf, we based it
on all the different
areas of the Gulf Sea.
And so I did have
some Cajun stuff.
And I made a really
good jambalaya risotto,
which basically you
just make a base risotto
and then add the ingredients
of a jambalaya to that.
We did the shrimp
brazed in molasses.
So that's probably the
extent of my Cajun cooking
but I do love eat it.
The andouille sausage?
Absolutely.
You can't have Cajun
food without that.
Probably not very traditional
to what it should be.
All right.
Go ahead and grab a
spoon and a parfait.
You can see in this once
you get into there the bits
and pieces of the almond too.
Yeah.
We'll put it on my
website, chefdakota.com
soon as we get home.
The dressing on those?
Kind of hard to get everything
on those little spoons.
But it serves the point.
So any last questions
on anything?
You can actually with it.
I've not made it, but the class
that I took to make yogurt,
they made it from coconut milk.
They did something
else really outrageous,
I was like oh my god.
It wasn't a nut though,
but it's really fun.
I think just as long as you've
got the temperatures right
and you let it sit long enough,
and you don't peak or poke
at it, it's going to happen.
Science, it's awesome.
Anything else?
You guys like it?
Good?
All right, well thank you
so much for coming in.
I appreciate it.
I don't.
Thank you.
Yeah, we didn't bring any.
We just brought a few
jars, but you can always
get some at chefdakota.com.
Just click on Pop Parlor.
So thanks again.
I appreciate it.